bonjour à tous aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous parler de la lumière
alors qu'est ce que c'est la lumière et
bien sur terre le jour la lumière c'est
le soleil qui nous la porte
la nuit l'homme inventé deux solutions
la première invention de l'homme à queue
en fait c'est le feu et la deuxième tout
aussi notable c'est l'électricité élan
foule dans la mer le soleil apporte
aussi de la lumière le jour
mais qu'est ce qui se passe la nuit tous
les animaux marins n'ont pas besoin de
dormir et plus vous descendez dans les
abysses plus la lumière se fait rare
donc comment font-ils pour se déplacer
pour se repérer pour se nourrir pour
chasser se reproduire ou encore pour
fuir les prédateurs et bien tout
simplement avec la bioluminescence c'est
une capacité naturelle qu'ont certains
organismes vivants à émettre de la
lumière sans électricité en fait 90 %
des espèces marines peuvent produire
cette bio luminescence est le mécanisme
moléculaire derrière cette lumière a été
caractérisée dans les années soixante
dix par les chercheurs en biologie
alors aujourd'hui c'est principalement
utilisé dans les laboratoires pour faire
du marquage génétique mais en fait cette
lumière bleue venus de la mer et le
centre de curiosité et d'intérêt depuis
bien plus longtemps que cela dans
l'antiquité déjà pline l'ancien disait
des méduses qu'elle brillait tellement
qu'on pouvait en faire des torches les
indiens d'amérique
utilisez des cours kouros ce sont des
petits insectes bioluminescence il
émettait dans des cages pour éclairer
leur maison le soir ils pouvaient aussi
s'en servir attachés à leur cheville
pour repousser les serpents à la nuit
tombée pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est la violer une naissance d
plancton dans le sillage des
porte-avions qui servait de point de
repère aux avions de chasse je pense que
vous l'avez bien compris la
bioluminescence elle est partout elle à
différentes formes
il ya de nombreux organismes vivant sur
la planète qui peuvent faire de la
bioluminescence à la fois marins des
crevettes des poissons des calamars des
méduses mais aussi terrestres des
lucioles des vers luisants des mousses
des champignons la bioluminescence est
aussi présente chez les bactéries et
c'est ces bactéries qui nous intéresse
chez glowy je vous vois venir des
bactéries a forcément c'est moins sexy
qu'une méduse aucun calamar et bien
figure figurez vous que le corps humain
contient 10 millions de fois plus de
bactéries que de cellules humaines
il ya les bactéries autour de vous sur
vous dans vous et c'est notamment grâce
à ces bactéries que vous êtes
aujourd'hui en bonne santé
nous on ne prend justement une bactérie
qui vient de votre appareil digestif
c'est une bactérie qui est très bien
connu qui est commune est utilisé dans
les laboratoires en biologie donc
comment on fait eh bien on vient prendre
le gène qui a responsable de la
bioluminescence ce gène est présent dans
une bactérie marine
cette bactérie est hébergé chez le
calamar et elle vit en symbiose avec son
hôte le canada il a une petite poche un
organe qui sert à mettre en culture ces
bactéries et lorsqu'il se sent menacé
il vient secouer la poche sécréter les
bactéries dans l'eau et ça va provoquer
un nuage de lumière qui va permettre de
distraire le prédateur et aux calamars
de s'enfuir alors si on a déjà des
bactéries marines pourquoi ne pas
directement les utiliser et bien tout
simplement puisqu'elles sont habitués à
des conditions extrêmes il faible
température et une pression beaucoup
plus élevé donc c'est très difficile de
les utiliser la surface ici c'est pour
cela que l'on s'intéresse seulement aux
gènes qui est responsable de la
bioluminescence
on prend ce gène et on vient de
l'insérer dans une autre bactérie
alors maintenant notre bactéries qui
possèdent ce gène pour faire de la
lumière ne peut toujours pas brillé
il lui manque quelque chose il lui
manque les bonnes conditions à savoir
des nutriments de l'eau de l'oxygène
donc un milieu de culture et une bonne
température pour la croissance et le
développement
une fois qu'on a réuni tout ça la
bactérie peut émettre de la lumière via
une réaction biochimique qui relâchent
des photos donc on prend cette solution
de bactéries on l'a mais avec une
solution gélifiée dans une coque qui est
transparente flexible et à des niveaux
surface this bon avec ça on peut faire
de la lumière sans électricité d'accord
et qu'est ce que cela change
comment cela va impacter notre manière
de faire et bien tout d'abord cela va
changer le paradigme de la lumière
la lumière n'est plus un objet ce n'est
plus une ampoule ou une aide mais c'est
une matière première matière vivante qui
se reproduit ses lumières qui a des
besoins des besoins en nutriments les
besoins en eau en oxygène c'est une
lumière qui ne dépend pas d'une source
extérieure de recharge comme le soleil
mais les panneaux photovoltaïques par
exemple ou encore la phosphorescence qui
est justement l'absorption de rayons du
soleil pourrait émettre de l'énergie de
la lumière plus tard notre produit peut
tout à fait briller sans avoir vu un
seul rayon de soleil est enfin une autre
caractéristique très intéressante à
notre produit c'est qu'ils ne
nécessitent pas d'infrastructures et les
flics vous n'avez pas besoin de relier
avec un câble votre ampoule à votre
centrale et les flics c'est autonome et
ça
ça change tout ça change la nature de la
lumière et ça fait une lumière qui
devient plus juste cette lumière
pourrait servir aux 1,2 milliard de
personnes qui vivent dans le noir
aujourd'hui il ya de nombreux enfants
dans les pays émergents qui sont en
échec de scolarité non pas qu'ils n'ont
pas accès aux écoles mais simplement car
il est trop difficile pour eux de
maintenir le niveau est de réussir car
ils ne peuvent pas à réviser relire ou
faire leurs exercices une fois la maison
il ya souvent peu ou pas de lumière et
une lumière à partager avec la famille
pour faire un an j'ai mangé c'est aussi
une lumière vivante qui pourraient être
utilisés pour réduire la part des 15 %
d'électricité utilisés dans la
production de la lumière au niveau
mondial et ses 15 % d'électricité selon
un responsable de 5% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre vous imaginez un
peu les chiffres on a donc une lumière
qui est plus juste et qui répond à la
fois des problématiques écologiques et
humaines on pourrait aussi utiliser
cette lumière là où elle est
actuellement interdite en france par
exemple il ya un décret qui date de 2013
qui a interdit l'éclairage des vitrines
la nuit d'hier et elle n'est pas du tout
respecté
aujourd'hui toutes les vitrines sont
encore allumée ou la plupart d'entre
elles sont encore allumée pourquoi
simplement parce que le commerçant ne
veut pas perdre en visibilité et ne veut
pas perdre de potentiels futurs clients
deuxième raison c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
policiers en fait pour mettre des pv la
nuit voilà le but de cette lumière
vivante n'est pas de remplacer le
lampadaire de demain mais plutôt de
diversifier les différentes énergies
utilisées dans l'éclairage public
le tout est vraiment utiliser la bonne
source d'énergie au bon endroit
si vous avez de l'éclairage de monuments
de l'éclairage de vitrine de la
signalétique ou encore dans le mobilier
urbain par rapport au mobilier urbain
par exemple
chaque année il ya de nombreux accidents
de la route à cause des poubelles
ça paraît tout bête mais les poubelles
ne sont que très peu visible par les
conducteurs de voitures de camions
ça fait énormément d'accidents et bien
simplement une bande réfléchissante ça
existe déjà
ce n'est pas suffisant mettre des led
avec des petites batteries sur vos
poubelles
je pense que vous comprenez tout ce que
c'est ça va être difficile alors encore
moins les raccorder au circuit
électrique
justement cette lumière biologiques
pourraient être utilisés là où
l'électricité est trop coûteuses ou trop
difficile à mener
imaginez dans des zones reculées des
pays émergents des parkings les
chantiers de construction des mines des
réserves naturelles aussi toutes ces
zones pourraient avoir leur lumière
autonome aujourd'hui le oui c'est ça
c'est un produit flexible et
personnalisable en en forme qui permet
un éclairage surfacique alors
aujourd'hui on à l'intensité d'une
petite veilleuse avec une durée des
missions de lumière constante pendant
trois jours dans un an nous prévoyons
d'avoir dix fois plus de lumière avec
une durée de vie d'un mois on compte
aussi avoir jusqu'à six couleurs allant
du vrai bleus le bleu vert qu'on a
actuellement un verre un jaune orange
rouge
alors comment on compte s'y prendre
il n'ya tout simplement comme on l'a
fait pour le premier prototype avec la
bioluminescence on va s'inspirer de la
nature
cela s'appelle du biomimétisme ou encore
de la bio inspiration si vous regardez
certaines méduses
elles ont des tentacules arc-en-ciel
multi couleurs il ya du rouge du bleu du
vert et ça clignote en plus et bien en
regardant le mécanisme moléculaire de
ses tentacules de méduses nous pouvons
tout à fait reproduire le même résultat
dans un produit qui ferait de
l'éclairage comment nous pourrions
atteindre
moins de lumière et bien déjà je vous ai
dit que notre produit
briet pendant trois jours de manière
constante c'est à dire aussi bien le
jour que la nuit
donc il y à une perte d'énergie est bien
là encore une fois on va regarder dans
la nature la nature qui a mis des
millions d'années a évolué à ce petit
musée
et il ya aussi la réponse cette fois
chez les plantes les plantes peuvent
très bien détectée quand est ce que
c'est le jour et quand est ce que c'est
la nuit elles ont des photos capteurs
qui sont sensibles à la lumière du
soleil et en fonction d'une certaine
exposition à la lumière
elles vont pouvoir réagir et déclencher
des activités au niveau de la cellule
eh bien c'est la même chose on va
s'inspirer des plantes et apprendre à
nos bactéries à se reposer le jour est
assez lumineux la nuit
bon certes on a un produit qui
maintenant pourrait faire donc jusqu'à
un mois de lumière vous me direz par
rapport aux led qui ont plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'heures de durée
de vie c'est l'équivalent de trois ans
si c'est une utilisation en continu 24
heures sur 24
c'est vrai que un mois par rapport à
trois ans on ne fait pas trop le poids
est bien en regardant justement une
analyse de cycle de vie de produit donc
c'est le total de coûts d'énergie et de
bilans carbone par rapport à
l'utilisation la production des
différents produits une vitrine de
magasin éclairé entièrement l'aide
serait dix fois plus émettrices de co2
qu'une vitrine de magasin éclairée par
la bioluminescence pourquoi simplement
parce qu'on a une matière vivante
matières premières qui se reproduit avec
une seule bactérie
j'en avais des milliards il leur suffit
seulement de grandir dans les bonnes
conditions
et ces conditions sont très peu coûteuse
et après
après nous pourrions imaginer d'autres
déclinaisons encore de cette violence
naissance nous pourrions imaginer que
cette culture de la lumière soit
accessible à tout le monde que chez vous
à la maison ou pourriez mettre en
culture de la lumière que qu'il y ait
des distributeurs en libre service dans
ces grands espaces publics pour récolter
votre lumière que la lumière pouce au
bord des routes
on pourrait aussi imaginer de la lumière
sous forme de poudre à utiliser comme
les feux d'artifices pour faire de
l'événementiel un flash de lumière en
lançant de la poudre cette lumière en
flash pourrait aussi servir en cas
d'urgence donc faire de la lumière
rapidement pour signaler un problème on
parle depuis tout à l'heure d'une
lumière qui a des besoins
un petit peu comme un aquarium que vous
devriez nourrir et bien on aime bien
pensé justement un système de recharge
pourquoi pas vous donner aussi des
recharges de lumière que le facteur de
demain pourrait venir vous livrer et
vous auriez vous même de quoi recharger
votre lumière
dernier point c'est pourquoi pas pensé
une matières premières bio luminescence
qui serait applicable à tout type de
surface et donc à tous types de produits
là les utilisations serait presque
infinies aujourd'hui je vous ai parlé
d'une lumière une lumière vivante cette
idée elle est venue dans la tête d'une
jeune designer qui ont regardé une
émission de télé sur les fonds marins
justement est aujourd'hui avec toute
l'équipe des glowy nous cultivons la
lumière de demain merci